good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight when permanent
washington pushes for war with russia
who benefits
we don't ask that question enough the
united states certainly doesn't benefit
that's obvious to anyone who thinks
about it for a second it's so glaringly
obvious in fact that the people pushing
this war immediately denounce you as a
traitor if you point that out
they're betraying our country's
interests but somehow you're the one
who's disloyal ukraine's borders are
sacred our borders are racist shut up
putin stooge but wait a second why is it
disloyal to side with russia
but loyal to side with ukraine they're
both foreign countries that don't care
anything about the united states kind of
strange
it's all an absurd performance but it's
all they've got in the end
the fact is ukraine is strategically
irrelevant to the united states no
rational person could defend a war with
russia over ukraine nobody thinks a war
like that would make america safer or
stronger or more prosperous
if you take a look at our economy
recently dangerous levels of inflation a
workforce in disarray wildly chaotic
swings in financial markets in case you
haven't noticed
will joining a conflict in eastern
europe fix any of that come on of course
not it'll make it worse
if the neocons aren't restrained and
soon americans are going to be a lot
poorer
so why are they doing this
that's a complex question hubris
stupidity the damaged psychological
makeup of our leaders massive lobbying
campaigns by ukrainian politicians and
american defense contractors
all of those factors play a role in this
no tragedy has a single cause
but what's not at all complicated is who
benefits from our conflict with russia
china benefits
period
the chinese government is the only
certain winner here we can give you many
examples to illustrate this but consider
the latest economic sanctions the white
house has proposed against russia
the bite administration may use
something called the foreign direct
product rule to cut off russia's supply
of semiconductors made with american
technology
this would in the hopeful assessment of
the washington post quote potentially
deprive russian citizens of some
smartphones tablets and video game
consoles
so depriving russian citizens is good
we're told because russian citizens are
bad
okay
but what are the long-term effects on us
russians are still going to have
smartphones they'll just get their
components somewhere else meaning from
china the chinese have already pledged
to help and they have every incentive to
make good on that promise
in other words the biden administration
will have succeeded in continuing to
drive our two main global rivals closer
to a permanent alliance with one another
how does that help america well it
doesn't
over time it's dangerous and not just
militarily the only reason the us
government can enforce international
sanctions is because the us dollar is
the world's reserve currency russia and
china don't like this obviously
so let's say they convinced other global
powers that the us government was
abusing its monopoly on monetary control
if they do it to us they might do it to
you they would say
and then other countries decided to drop
the us dollar in favor of a new currency
where would that leave us
well suddenly the united states would no
longer be able to run an economy based
on debt
we would be impoverished immediately
overnight
has no one in washington thought of this
apparently not imposing tough new
sanctions every few months
feeds their moral vanity it makes them
feel like good people what fools they
are
both parties by the way participate in
this preening about sanctions on
television is a lot easier than
improving the lives of people in your
own country so that's what they do
here's republican senator joni ernst of
iowa telling you that protecting
ukraine's sacred borders is much more
important than say saving americans in
des moines from overdosing on drugs
watch
so we do need to go ahead and impose
sanctions on russia now we need to show
them that we mean business and we will
be there for ukraine should they invade
certainly we need to make sure that any
defensive aid is in the hands of the
ukrainians as well as as much lethal aid
as we can provide at this time
those are our leaders totally ignorant
just reading the script if nice to hear
someone in the press corps because it's
their job ask the obvious follow-up
which would be
why exactly senator ernst do you believe
it's so vital to send more lethal aid to
ukraine and to quote go ahead and impose
more sanctions on russia
why
how would she answer that question we'll
never know how she'd answer because no
one in the media would ever ask her
reporters are the most bovine of the
herd animals if the other kids say it's
a good idea they assume that it is
journalists feel that way about
everything but especially about armed
conflict
the longest war in american history just
ended this fall when we left afghanistan
the new consensus in washington is we
need another war now and that view is
especially prevalent in tv news
watch this teleprompter jockey try to
push our russia-hating secretary of
state into hating russia even more
we are proceeding on both paths at the
same time we'll be ready either way the
choice is vladimir putin's
but what are you negotiating if russia's
demands are non-starters i mean
president biden has already said
ukraine's not going to join nato anytime
soon you've made this offer of
reciprocal military exercises what's
left to talk about
what's left to talk about too much
diplomacy mr secretary not enough
killing
that's her position apparently
max blue to the washington post
fervently agrees with this at this point
every project in max boot's life has
collapsed into disaster from his
personal affairs to the war in iraq
which he promoted endlessly having come
to middle age max boot is unequivocally
a failure but he's looking for one last
war to redeem it all he's thinking
conflict with nuclear-armed russia could
be that war
watch
we should be arming the ukrainians like
crazy
we should be preparing for a guerrilla
warfare
if the russians go in and i think the
most important thing we can do right now
is to lay out a menu of sanctions so
that putin knows exactly what's going to
happen to him if he goes over the line
because right now with these vague
threats he can be left with the feeling
well
maybe the us and the in the europeans
maybe we're not really going to do
anything again you have to ask yourself
why is it more quote patriotic to take
one countryside than the other
countryside
we have no obligation to defend any
country either one of these countries
neither one is american neither one has
the same interests as we do
why is it wrong to support one and not
the other
what's wrong is to support either one of
them their interests are not the same as
ours they're very different max boot
doesn't care arm the ukrainians prepare
for guerrilla warfare
only a man completely insulated from the
consequences of his blood lust could
talk like that there will always be
another think tank job for max boot and
people like max boot
but what's politico's excuse
the fascially liberal political blog has
been pushing for war in ukraine for
months now
why what's in it for them well let's see
a few days ago politico published this
terrifying headline quote sucky
russia could at any point launch an
attack in ukraine the piece goes on to
promise that quote experts and policy
makers are now preparing for a range of
escalatory measures
well that sounds scary we better send
billions more in military hardware to
ukraine right away
beneath the headline you learn why
politico is interested because the story
is quote presented by lockheed martin
aha in other words defense contractors
think it is high time to spend much more
on defense contracting in ukraine
politico is happy to make their case in
exchange for money
over the washington post you may have
seen this op-ed with this headline quote
biden must show that the united states
stands ready to support ukraine
militarily if necessary
now that piece was written by a man
called michael vickers who's michael
vickers among other things michael
vickers sits on the board of the weapons
contractor bae systems
now that would seem relevant because war
with russia would be potentially in any
case highly profitable for bae systems
but somehow the washington post didn't
bother to tell readers about this it
remained undisclosed
so how does this look from across the
world well the chinese must be watching
this happen with their jaws open
completely delighted they can't believe
their good fortune
they watch as the entire political
leadership class of the united states
runs at full speed in the wrong
direction
away from asia which is so clearly the
future and toward the murky past on the
fringes of eastern europe ukraine russia
and the chinese must be wondering
how could these people be so stupid and
so self-destructive hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else